Well,
so what happens with with Abraham?
he's at home and these angels show up.
Now
we don't know whether they're angels or
men precisely because while as this part
of the story reads,
as the Lord appeared to him in the
plains of camera and he sat in the tent
door in the heat of the day,
so he's another visionary state by the,
by all appearances,
and he lifted up his eyes and looked and
lo three men stood by him.
There's real ambivalence in the story
about the man or the three men are the
three angels are there to angels and
God.
It's all mixed up in the story.
So we will clarify that.
We'll leave it ambiguous and I think the
ambiguity is important because you don't
know who the stranger is when you
encounter them and it depends on whether
you're thinking about it
in the normative manner or if you're
thinking about it in the transcendent
manner.
Because with each person that you meet,
well,
they're just a person.
That's one way of thinking about it and
then they're the person that you know or
they're the person as they choose to
reveal themselves to you when people
keep themselves shielded,
but then there also something of great
metaphysical potential,
right?
And you might say,
well,
do you believe that?
And I would say,
well,
yes,
you believe it because you expect a lot
from people generally speaking and are
not happy if they betray you,
but more importantly,
our entire culture is predicated on the
idea that each person has an indefinite
intrinsic worth.
And I'm not talking about self esteem.
I'm talking about something like the
what,
what would you say it?
The implicit presupposition in our legal
structure that no matter who you are,
even if you're a murderer,
even if you're a condemned murderer,
that there's something about you that's
of transcendent value that has to be
respected by the law,
by the law and by other people.
Right?
And so that's,
that's a remark.
And you might say,
well,
you know,
do I believe that the answer that is,
well,
you act it out because you follow the
law and it's not an easy thing to pull
out of the law.
It's kind of the idea that you have
intrinsic natural rights and you don't
pull that out of our law man without
having the whole thing fall down.
And I think the whole idea that you have
intrinsic natural rights is predicated
on something like the biblical
hypothesis that human beings have,
a logos nature and that we are involved
in this speaking forth of being and as
beings who are,
who are involved in this speaking forth
of being.
There's something about us that has to
be respected by,
by ourselves,
in relationship to ourselves,
in relationship to other people,
but even more strangely by ourselves in
relationship to even to criminals,
even to vicious criminals.
You can't remove that transcendent
element and that's that to me,
that's also a mirror,
a miracle of conceptualization because
who the hell is going to think that up?
Right?
Even the most vicious of murderers has a
touch of the transcendent that needs to
be respected of all the ideas that are
unlikely,
that's going to top the list,
and of course without that,
you have a very barbaric legal system,
right?
Because no one is protected.
As soon as you make a mistake,
then you're in the dam,
then you have no rights whatsoever,
and that isn't what happens in the West,
which is an absolutely amazing thing.
So anyways,
Abraham is a master of the stranger.
That's one way of thinking about it.
He knows what to do when strangers come
along and he opens his.
He opens himself up to them and I would
say he does that.
We know he's not a naive guy,
Abraham,
right?
He's no weakling.
A couple of stories ago,
he took a big army and went and harassed
a bunch of kings and took his nephew
back.
He's,
he's a tough guy.
And so if stranger show up and he
welcomes them,
it's not because he couldn't do
otherwise.
He could certainly do otherwise,
and it's not because he isn't aware of
what people can be like.
He's perfectly aware of what people can
be like,
but he determines to take a particular
attitude towards them and that is to
welcome them and so and why would you do
that?
And I think the answer to that is you
hold out your hand in trust to someone
and you evoke the best from them if
that's there to be given.
So it's an act of courage.
It's like it's.
It isn't me meeting you.
Exactly,
not exactly.
It's more like the transcendent part of
me making a gesture that allows the
transcendent part of you to step forward
and that happens all the time.
It happens all the time in normative
discourse.
You know this perfectly well because
sometimes you can have a real casual
conversation with someone that just goes
nowhere,
right?
It's just shallow as can be or now,
and then you can actually make contact
with someone.
Right?
And you're both,
I would say enlightened and Ennobles by
the conversation and that's a deal.
We would call that a deep conversation
fruit for some reason because we made a
deep connection.
Whatever that means,
it means well.
It certainly means that it's not
shallow.
We were not sure about what these
metaphor means,
but it means that it reaches deep inside
of you.
It's something like that.
You make direct person to person contact
and those sorts of conversations are,
I'm replenishing that that's the right
way to think about it.
They they genuinely are and I think
that's because they provide you with
that bread that's not material bread and
that's the information that you need to
to thrive and to put yourself together
and so it does matter how you meet
someone and it doesn't matter how you
treat them when you first meet them and
it's amazing.
I've learned to do this at least in
part,
partly because I'm a clinical
psychologist.
I've learned how to talk to people very
rapidly and I have the most amazing
adventures with people in cabs and when
I travel because I'll talk to them
directly right away and they'll tell me
the wildest stories and show me the
craziest things because I'm actually
interested in what they have to say and
I'm not afraid.
Well,
I'm somewhat afraid,
but I'm not.
I'm not sufficiently afraid to have that
stopped me and I'm acting on the
presupposition that
the person has something of great
interest to reveal and that's a very
useful thing to know too,
because one of the things that's really
cool about people that are you really
learned this as a clinical psychologist
is that if you can get people talking,
they're so damn interesting.
You can hardly stand it.
You know,
because they have these idiosyncratic
experiences that are only.
There's only.
There's personally no one else could
tell the story and that's the kind of
stories that you want to hear.
And when they tell you those stories,
you learn something you didn't know.
And so what that means is that you can
treat the landscape of strangers as an
endless vista of places to learn things
you didn't know.
And if you know enough so that you're
satisfied with your life and everything
has ceased to be a tragedy around you.
Well then you can be comfortable in your
circumscribed domain of totalitarian
knowledge,
let's say.
But if you're.
If your life is insufficient and you're
suffering more than you want to and
everything isn't what it should be,
then you need to look where you haven't
looked for what you don't have and then
you can look outside beyond you and then
you can make friends with what you don't
understand,
and that's a huge part of what this
story's about because what happens is
that Abraham welcomes the men,
God angels and treats them very well and
reaps a tremendous benefit as a
consequence,
and then,
well then the story reverses and we end
up in Sodom and Gomorrah were the same
angels sojourn and they're treated
terribly and all hell breaks loose,
and so that's what the story's about.
It's fundamentally now there's A.
There's a sexual impropriety thing going
on that I'm also going to delve into,
but I don't think that's the critical
issue in the story.
The critical issue in the story is how
do you act in the face of the stranger?
You know there's a statement in the New
Testament,
Christ says something like,
when you,
when you do something to the least of
people,
you do it to me.
Him Right,
and that's a very
difficult statement to understand too,
but it's something like it's something
reminiscent of the requirement to keep
the idea of the transcendent reality of
the person in mind at the same time.
You keep their proximal reality in mind
to have to have your mind in two places
at the same time when you're talking to
people,
you know,
I learned from a friend of mine in
Montreal who's very socially
sophisticated and in some ways,
um,
whenever,
whenever he went into a star wars,
like going shopping with him and
whenever he went into a store and he
talked and he had an interaction with a
clerk,
the first thing he would do is have an
interaction with the clerk.
You know,
he wouldn't have any interaction with
the role of the clerk.
He'd like look at the person,
sort of take stock of the fact that they
were there and then ask them something
genuine about their job or their store,
how they were doing,
like go into a conversation right away
and he didn't get personal about it
because that can be intrusive.
Right?
Do you have to be very sophisticated to
do this?
But he did indicate to the person that
he was there,
at least in part for the good that could
be done between them.
It's something like that.
And then the person would be
ridiculously helpful,
you know,
and,
and so then you know,
if people mistreat you,
you see this with anti social kids.
It's very tragic thing to see because if
you're an antisocial child by the time
you were above four,
your very hostile and distrustful to
people and so you'd like a growling
puppy and if you're a growling puppy,
you tend not to get petted.
You're more likely to get kicked.
And if you're growling puppy and you get
kicked and you have even more reason to
grow.
And that's sort of the story of
antisocial kids.
If they're not well socialized by the
time they're four and they're more on
the aggressive side than they alienate
themselves from the community.
And all they get is rejection while.
And then they look at the rejection and
they think,
well hell with humanity.
You know,
and no wonder they think that.
But,
but the part of the catastrophe is,
is that they get what they evoke and,
and I'm not saying it's their fault
precisely,
but it doesn't matter.
That's still what happens.
And so you might ask yourself,
if you're not getting from people what
you need,
there is some possibility that you're
not approaching,
especially if this happens to you
repeatedly across people.
And this is a virtual certainty.
If it happens to you repeatedly across
people,
especially if you have the same bad
experience with people,
it's not them,
it's you.
I would say three is the limit.
If something happens to you,
once
you write it off,
if it happens to you twice,
it's like you open your eyes,
but you write it off.
But if it happens to you three times,
it's probably you or as the rest of the
world better.
It's you because you're not going to
change the rest of the world.